[Music]  the first presidential debate of course  is tomorrow evening for the past week  both Mitt Romney and President Obama  have you noticed this they've been  trying to lower expectations for their  debate performance by insisting that  they're not Great Debaters yeah and some  people think that the two candidates are  grossly exaggerating I'm not so sure  based on some of their past debates  tomorrow could look like this but I want  to and I want to I don't know let me  just make a couple of points my  definition  here's I hope they either take off the  air to make it or make it correct look  let's just be clear  we hired a lawn lawn company to demo our  lawn and I but my wife we thought we had  what we but let's see we could start  with that with his idea to have a lunar  colony that would mine minerals from it  from a moon you said that it well though  let me just make a closing point that  made no sense whatsoever  [Applause]